what do you think about him stepping
away from uh the world championship are
you a romantic about the World
Championships no I'm not a romantic
about anything I don't think I I can't
imagine what dark
it went dark quickly I don't think I'm
sophisticated enough to be a romantic I
think I uh you know I I taught chess and
now I make YouTube videos I'm not
qualified on the subject of Romanticism
but I you don't think it's a beautiful
game chess yeah no I think I I think it
is a beautiful there you go I got you
yeah is that is that considered being a
romantic yeah I'm seeing the beauty in
the you can be like Bach and seeing the
math and the music where you can see the
beauty
the magic I think I see beauty in
certain types of chests for sure not in
all chess so I'll partially romantic
part-time romantic yeah yeah so what I
mean what what do you feel about Magnus
stepping away from the world
championships
disappointing but understandable can you
still man his case what what what's
understandable about it to you
I don't think it's as prestigious as it
could be I don't think the world
championship yeah yeah why does Magnus
still sign everything as world champion
then that's a good point that that he
did just put out a statement and he did
but he does it everywhere else too does
he really yeah like world champion right
world champion I don't know World
Championship World chess champion maybe
it's just because he he he wanted but he
thinks that the journey to the top once
again to maintain the status quo has
lost its appeal but you know what the
example that I like to I like to make I
I'm a big fan of UFC so we've never
really seen with the exception of George
St-Pierre
walking and and could be but khabib was
kind of a different story walking away
from
a belt
at the absolute Zenith of their career
but also in the UFC Champions are
extremely well taken care of and the
Champions have some of the best some of
the best lives of course you can argue
not all Champions you can say some of
the lower weight divisions yes but what
I'm saying is a lot of them get all the
sponsors they get massive massive
paydays they're International
celebrities I don't think chess has that
in fact the world championship of Chess
price fund has not changed much in like
40 years so you could probably make more
money on uh on YouTube yes playing
randos not randos but other having fun
and playing challenging really
challenging games playing other super
Grand Masters like and ad hoc events
um or maybe a little bit organized
events but not the world championship
yes and still and still have a lot of
fun make a lot of money
um get everybody excited all that kind
of stuff yeah so for Magna specifically
and we're using him because he's the
world champion if you tally if he wins
every tournament that he plays in over
the course of a year which is really not
even that crazy of an estimate because
that's really how it seems sometimes
yeah I don't know how much money that is
I haven't tallied but if he dedicated an
entire year to being managed on social
media and doing various things and
growing all his Brands and getting
sponsor deals I think he would make five
times more than being the world champion
which is crazy yeah but money isn't
everything I know that's that's totally
unable to dedicate their whole life to
winning the Olympics the Olympics is a
funny is an interesting one too because
like I didn't even watch the the
Olympics as carefully as I usually do
this year yeah yeah neither it's it's
really strange I'm not sure why that is
when during covid
I'm not sure that's that was weird I
don't know if it's losing its magic part
of it is also the people that own the
Olympics and the way they distribute it
they make it a little bit more difficult
to watch like it should in my opinion it
should all be just available on YouTube
and
uh easily accessible it's like the
difference between
like uh SpaceX and and uh some other
organ like even NASA just SpaceX is
better at streaming their launches and
commentating them and it they've made
NASA better as well but just like the
ability it sounds ridiculous but
making it more frictionless for people
to watch get excited to share all that
kind of stuff yeah like I'm not exactly
sure where
the magic
like balances between the The Classy
traditional World Championships and the
kind of
dramatic exciting streamer world
and it feels like for for the World
Championships to be relevant they have
to find that balance
yeah well this recent one had
I was it's pretty good commentating yeah
no I I'm not I'm not even necessarily
talking about myself there was a lot of
that was the worst part for me
there was well everybody you did amazing
yeah I appreciate that it was a lot of
uh I was a big arms race so every
major chess platform try to get one
super Grand Master
you name it they were they were
basically involved and to to go back to
that point yeah I the big question is
money and if if Magnus is not motivated
by money if the price went for the next
World Championship was 10 million
dollars would he play it if he says no
Then it must be something else it must
just be a matter of
something's not worth it it's not worth
it you got to take him in his word and
his word is like
there's too much stress to the little
sample play yeah like I want to play
many more times yeah he wants to play
more he wants to kill him yeah exactly
yeah more shorter games like where you
can
um increase the possibility of Pure
Chess
whatever the heck that means but we
can't go back to the first carp of
Kasparov match which they have to stop
due to health concerns I mean the guy
went down five nil and it was first to
six wins and draws didn't count so draws
didn't a mass to the total score there
was no best of system so what happened
there the match went something like
seven eight months Kasparov started
making a comeback after being down five
nothing he was five three and they
called it off they called it off they
said both players are in poor health
conditions because far of stormed down
yelled that this is a farce and but the
match was 50 games long it would even
more maybe I made a video and I don't
even remember how many games it was it
was so long can you imagine Bobby
Fischer wanted something almost as
extreme draw Stone Calendar's first one
to ten wins and if it's nine nine
the world champion retains his title so
you have to beat the world champion 10-8
that's the only way so you don't like
that
but it's just grueling I don't know
maybe I like it for the YouTube Recaps
but do I like it for the players do I
like it for general public no for sure
yes three four hours right you imagine
your favorite tennis match was six
months long
what are we doing yeah yeah there's
still a magic to the world championship
I wish they could make it some
interesting
yeah they make it work somehow
but Matt I think Magnus is really
challenging fee day and everybody else
to step up and try to figure that out
which is great ultimately